>> Julie: WHEN THOSE COMMENTS,
AND WE WILL BRING THEM TO YOU
LIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, PETER DOOCY
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
FORMER ACTING HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY TO TALK MORE ABOUT
THIS.
LET’S JUST TALK ABOUT THE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS AS A WHOLE.
JEN PSAKI ACTUALLY WON’T EVEN
ADDRESS IT AS AN ACTUAL CRISIS.
NANCY PELOSI CALLS IT A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
IT SEEMS THEY CAN’T GET THEIR
VOCAB TO MATCH, BUT NEVER MIND
WHAT YOU CALL IT, IT DOESN’T
MATTER.
THE POINT IS IT IS INDEED A
CRISIS.
KAMALA HARRIS, WHERE IS SHE?
SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE LOOKING AT
THE ROOT CAUSE OF IT, THAT IS
THE JOB SHE WAS GIVEN.
WHERE IS KAMALA HARRIS AND ALL
OF THIS?
>> YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WHETHER YOU CALL IT A CRISIS OR
A CHALLENGE, THE REALITY IS WE
ARE SEEING HISTORIC NUMBERS ON
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER.
THE LEGAL APPREHENSIONS OF
MINORS AND FAMILIES, MOST OF
THEM BEING RELEASED INTO THE
U.S.
THE BORDER PATROL IS
OVERWHELMING DHS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES SO ANYWAY YOU CUT IT
THERE IS A CRISIS OF THE BOARD
OF THE DOESN’T SEEM TO BE
MOVING.
THERE ARE NO POLICIES THAT WILL
STEM THE FLOW OF MIGRANTS COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY.
YOU SHOW THE VIDEO OF THE TWO
YOUNG GIRLS BEING THROWN OVER A
BORDER FENCE.
THAT IS THE DIRECT RESULT OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION ADVERTISING
THAT IT IS OKAY THAT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW MINORS TO STAY
IN THE COUNTRY IF THEY ARRIVE AT
THE BORDER.
IT’S AN INHUMANE POLICY AND WE
ARE SEEING THE RESULTS OF THAT.
>> Julie: THE VIDEO IS JUST
HORRIFYING.
THE TWO LITTLE GIRL TODDLERS ARE
PLOPPED DOWN ONTO OUR SIDE OF
THE BORDER, THERE IS THE AGENT
WHO RESCUED THESE TWO LITTLE
GIRLS.
NOW THEY HAVE NO FAMILY, NOW
THEY JOIN THE 5,767 CHILDREN IN
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL, ON
TRACK TO RECORD, WHAT IS THE
PLAN TO MAKE IT STOP?
FORGET THE FOCUS ON THE ROOT OF
THE CAUSE, HOW ABOUT JUST THE
SOLUTION?
>> THAT IS JUST IT.
AGAIN, I HAVE SAID THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION, TRYING TO BRING
IN MORE FACILITIES AND BRING IN
MORE INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
COUNTRY AND THAT IS THE WRONG
APPROACH.
YOU’VE GOT TO ADDRESS THE
ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR THAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER TO STOP
THE FLOW, TO STOP THE TIDE THAT
IS COMING IN AND THE SURGE THAT
IS COMING IN, THAT IS NOT THEIR
FOCUS TODAY.
I URGE THEM TO CHANGE COURSE IN
DOING THAT.
TALK ABOUT THE MINORS, THERE ARE
OVER 5,000, ABOUT 5,000 IN
CUSTODY.
ANOTHER 7,000 OR 8,000 IN HHS
CUSTODY AND FOR DHS THAT IS
ALMOST DOUBLE WHAT WE SAW IN THE
HEIGHT OF THE CRISIS IN 2019
WHEN SO MANY ON THE FAR LEFT AND
OTHERS WERE SO OUTRAGED AT WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN THE BORDER, THEY
HAVE DOUBLED THE AMOUNT OF
MINORS IN FACILITIES TODAY.
AND AGAIN, THE DIRECT RESULT OF
THESE POLICIES THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN PURSUING SINCE INAUGURATION
DAY.
THERE ARE WAYS TO FIX THIS AND
BORDER PATROL AND DHS CAN STEM
THE TIDE VERY, VERY QUICKLY.
>> Julie: I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT ANOTHER GROWING
CRISIS.
IT’S A NEW FOX NEWS ANALYSIS
WHICH SHOWS THAT CRIMES SURGING
DEMOCRAT LED CITIES THAT/FUNDING
LAST YEAR.
THIS IS AN ISSUE, MURDERS UP 46%
IN MINNEAPOLIS, 270% IN
PORTLAND, OREGON, 12% HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY, 28% IN
LOS ANGELES AND IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY, MORE
CONTROVERSY AROUND NEW DISTRICT
ATTORNEY GEORGE GASCON WHO
CRITICS CALL PRO-CRIMINAL.
THEY SAY HE IS PLANNING TO
RENAME THE CITY’S HARD-CORE GANG
UNIT.
THE SISTER OF A MAN KILLED BY A
GANG MEMBER IS SPEAKING THIS,
WATCH.
>> I CAN’T BELIEVE HE IS
ACTUALLY MAKING THIS ACTION.
IT WAS ACTUALLY THE WORK OF THE
GANG UNIT AND THE HARD-CORE GANG
UNIT IN THE D.A.’S OFFICE THAT
KIND OF PULLED THIS CASE
TOGETHER.
IT IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
THESE GANGS ARE VERY, VERY REAL
AND THEY ARE VERY, VERY
DANGEROUS.
IN THE CASE OF MY BROTHER,
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE CAUSING
CROSS FIRE, THE GANG ACTIVITY.
>> Julie: THIS IS NO SURPRISE,
AN UPTICK IN CRIME WHERE
DIFFERENT DEMOCRATIC LED
COUNTIES ARE REDUCING THEIR
BUDGETS FOR POLICE.
WHAT DID THEY EXPECT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN?
THAT ALL CRIMINALS WERE GOING TO
GO INTO HIDING?
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT LAST SUMMER, TO
REALLY LOOK CLOSELY AT
PROCEDURES.
WHAT WE DID IN THE TRUMP A
ADMINISTRATION AS WE SET UP SOME
REFORM PRINCIPLES WE BELIEVE THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY COULD
BACK ABOUT WHAT WE SAW FROM THE
LEFT IS GOING VERY MUCH BEYOND
THAT AND GOING DEEP ON THE
POLICE, TAKE DOWN GANG UNITS
OTHER MEASURES.
WE SEE THE DRAMATIC AND
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT THAT THAT IS
HAVING AND WE SEE PLACES LIKE
MINNEAPOLIS AND PORTLAND THAT
ARE NOW TRYING TO RETRACT SOME
OF THE MEASURES THAT THEY TOOK
OVER THE SUMMER, BUT IT IS
CERTAINLY NOT WORKING AND SOME
OF THESE BIG CITIES THAT HAVE
THIS APPROACH WHETHER IT IS
SEATTLE, MINNEAPOLIS, PORTLAND,
THERE’S THREE OR FOUR OTHERS,
THEY ARE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, THEY ARE GOING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION AND THEY NEED TO
TAKE A PLAYBOOK OUT OF SOME OF
THOSE OTHER LARGE CITIES THAT
HAVE MADE POLICE REFORM NOT ONLY
PROSPEROUS, IN THE SENSE OF
MAKING SURE YOU ARE BRINGING IN
MORE LEADERSHIP AND TRAINING TO
POLICE IN A VERY PRODUCTIVE WAY.
>> Julie: HERE’S WHAT I WANT
TO KNOW, I WANT TO KNOW WHERE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION STANDS
ON ALL OF THIS BECAUSE HE
REMEMBERED THERE WAS A
BACK-AND-FORTH WHETHER JOE BIDEN
SUPPORTED THE POLICE ALMANAC
DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENTS OR
DIDN’T, AND HE DID COME FORWARD
SAID THAT HE DID NOT SUPPORT
DEFUND THE POLICE BUT HE THOUGHT
THAT EACH CITY OR EACH COUNTY
NEEDED TO DEAL WITH IT ON ITS
OWN.
AT WHAT POINT DOES THE BY
ADMINISTRATION STAND UP AND TELL
THESE COUNTIES, THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO BE FLASHING BUDGETS.
IF THERE HAS EVER BEEN A TIME TO
GET BEHIND THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
BLUE, PROTECTING INNOCENT
CIVILIANS, THE TIME IS NOW.
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE LARGEST
MICROPHONE OUT THERE.
WHEN HE SPEAKS OR MEMBERS OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION SPEAK, SOME FOLKS
DO LISTEN.
THEY NEED TO COME OUT AND
SUPPORT THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
BLUE, THEY NEED TO BACK
LAW ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THESE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES BIG AND SMALL AND
THEY NEED TO HAVE THE BACKING OF
THEIR COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
THE PRESIDENT AND EVERY WEEK
THAT HE IS SILENT AND HE DOESN’T
TALK ABOUT THIS, WE SEE THE NEWS
IN PORTLAND, THEY ARE STILL
TARGETING FEDERAL FACILITIES AND
AGENTS IN PORTLAND TODAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SILENT ON
THAT.
IT SEEMS THE ONLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE EVENTS OF JANUARY 6
HERE IN D.C. BUT IF THERE IS
VIOLENCE TOWARDS OTHER FEDERAL
OFFICERS OR FACILITIES, THEY